Pride and Prejudice in the world of a
zombie apocalypse I am intrigued I am on
board with this there's no way this
movie's gonna have wonky pacing anywhere
in it Pride and Prejudice and Zombies so
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies is
ultimately the Jane Austen novel Pride
and Prejudice in the world of a zombie
apocalypse with zombies sprinkled in and
I do mean sprinkled in because as we
have seen in the world of zombie shows
and zombie movies I mean there's zombies
everywhere in our entertainment world
the fact that something takes place in a
zombie world doesn't necessarily make
the zombies the forefront and the point
of the story it's usually the characters
in the story interacting but it just
happens to take place in a zombie world
that's the case with this movie that
being said I could have gone for a
little less Pride and Prejudice a little
more zombies don't get me wrong this
movie had some cool stuff had some cool
zombie scenes I've seen where the guy
likes saws a zombie's head off and his
from the first person of the zombies saw
in the trailer and the head drops out
and he steps on has that's actually at
the beginning of the movie but nothing
in the subsequent two hours following
that scene is as interesting as that
shot the late actress was cool I thought
she was a kick-ass chick did a kick-ass
job but really it's two hours of we want
to get married to suitors and it's Pride
and Prejudice
now you're ultimately putting up with
another love triangle movie just happens
to take place in the zombie apocalypse
and do both the male love interests have
to sound like Christian Bale from The
Dark Knight I'm sorry I can't do that
Emma very damaged man yeah it's okay to
have people talk normal in a movie
I'm just saying and really I remember
when the interesting point hit the movie
I actually looked at my watch is err
okay we've been here for an hour and
then the interesting concept actually
revealed itself then after that more
souter and love triangle stuff and
the fact that the concept sounds really
cool I'm sure it's a great book I'm sure
the book you're reading you're like hey
this is just Brighton Prejudice but a
zombie world and it probably should have
stayed a book I mean just things that
are books don't always translate well to
scream I'm just saying this movie grinds
to a halt on more than a few occasions
it has wonky pacing some weird editing
choices where you look at the editing
and you're like I sure if you thought
that was a good idea why not now if you
have read Pride and Prejudice or you
like this story I feel like you're gonna
have more fun with this movie because
you're gonna enjoy the integration of
the zombie world into the story you know
you're gonna pick out the parallels
you're gonna be having a better time I
feel like I have to say this movie is
more geared
towards fans of Pride and Prejudice less
geared towards fans of zombie movies in
that I'm not the demographic this movie
missed me it was kind of wasted on me
admittedly there were some cool zombie
scenes in this movie but their 10th
feeling far between between the boring
ass love story among characters you
don't really care a lot about I don't
care about this man girls sisters I just
don't give a so in the end Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies had a good
lead character and has an interesting
concept and a cool concept but the
execution that execution being some of
the pacing that just puts you to sleep
in a zombie apocalypse movie the other
characters really aren't interesting at
all the climax of the movie looks like
it's gonna get interesting you're like
alright well no it's just still not
there are much better zombie movies out
there and there are much better romance
movies out there so I will say Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies I'm probably not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day ya
already forgot alright guys so Pride
Prejudice and Zombies have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite zombie apocalypse movie
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]